what if you could take a pill or a
vaccine and just like getting over a
cold you could heal your wounds faster
today if we have an operation or an
accident we're in the hospital for weeks
and often left with scars and painful
side effects of our inability to
regenerate or regrow healthy uninjured
organs I work to create materials that
instruct our immune system to give us
the signals to grow new tissues just
like vaccines instruct our body to fight
disease we could instead instruct our
immune system to build tissues and more
quickly heal wounds
now regrowing body parts out of nowhere
it might seem like magic but there's
several organisms that can achieve this
feat some lizards can regrow their tails
the humble salamander can completely
regenerate their arm and even us mere
humans can regrow our liver after losing
more than half of its original mass to
make this magic a bit closer to reality
I'm investigating how our body can heal
wounds and build tissue through
instructions from the immune system from
a scrape on your knee to that annoying
sinus infection our immune system
defends our body from danger I'm an
immunologist and by using what I know
about our body's defense system I was
able to identify a key players in our
fight to build back our cuts and bruises
when looking at materials that are
currently being tested for their
abilities to help regrow muscle our team
noticed that after treating an injured
muscle with these materials there was a
large number of immune cells in that
material and the surrounding muscle so
in this case instead of the immune cells
rushing off to an infection to fight
bacteria they're rushing toward an
injury I discovered a specific type of
immune cell the helper t-cell was
present inside that material that I
implanted and absolutely critical for
wound healing now just like when you
were a kid and you'd break your pencil
and try and tape it back together again
we can feel but it might not be in the
most functional way and we'll get a scar
so if we don't have these helper t-cells
instead of healthy muscle our muscle
develops fat cells inside of it and if
there's fat in our muscle it isn't as
strong now using our immune system our
body could grow back without these scars
and look like what it was before we were
even injured I am working to create
materials that give us the signals to
build new tissue by changing the immune
response
we know that anytime a material is
implanted in our body the immune system
will respond to it this ranges from
pacemakers to insulin pumps to the
materials that engineers are using to
try and build new tissue so when I place
that material or scaffold in the body
the immune system creates a small
environment of cells and proteins that
can change the way that our stem cells
behave now just like the weather affects
our daily activities like going for a
run or staying inside and binge watching
the entire TV show on Netflix the immune
environment of a scaffold affects the
way that our stem cells grow and develop
if we have the wrong signals say the
Netflix signals we get fat cells instead
of muscle these scaffolds are made of a
variety of different things from
plastics to naturally drive materials
nano fibers of varying thicknesses
sponges that are more or less porous
gels of different stiffnesses and
researchers can even make the materials
release different signals over time so
in other words we can orchestrate this
Broadway show of cells by giving them
the correct stage cues and props so they
can be changed for different tissues
just like a producer would change the
set for layman's versus Little Shop of
Horrors I am combining specific types of
signals that mimic how our body responds
to energy injury to help us regenerate
in the future we could see a scar proof
band-aid a moldable muscle filler or
even a wound healing vaccine now we
aren't going to wake up tomorrow and be
able to heal like Wolverine probably not
next Tuesday either
but with these advances and working with
our immune system it's helped build
tissue and heal wounds we could begin
seeing products on the market that work
with our body's defense system to help
us regenerate and maybe one day be able
to keep pace with a salamander thank you
[Applause]
[Music]